Lemercier arrive dans les
♪ I get wings to fly ♪
de Valérie Lemercier, inspiré
de la vie de Céline Dion,
fait un carton en France.
VALÉRIE LEMERCIER, réalisatrice,
- J'ai tellement regardé Céline
chanter, parler dans toute
les langues, à tous les âges,
qu'elle est rentrée
- Au côté de Valérie Lemercier,
dans cette copro
franco-canadienne, des acteurs
québécois comme Danielle
la mère de la chanteuse.
DANIEL, comédienne
- Moi, je la voulais aimante,
bienveillante, maman ourse.
l'ascension spectaculaire
d'une aux origines
modestes et une histoire
d'amour aux accents de comédie
incarne l'impresario de la diva.
N MARCEL, comédien
- Il y a trois personnes qui ont
vraiment aimé Céline : il gélil
et il y a Valérie Lemercier;puin
dit. Elle a fait quelque chose
de beau, de doux, de tendrmoquee
dans le film.
- Nous avons demandé à des fans
de Céline Dion de nous donner
leurs impression9 concerts9 conn
dans sa vie. Le film ne l'a pas
convaincu.
ESTEVAM PERIC, fan de Céline
émotion qu'elle a voulu donner
était là. Mais quand on regarde
l'ensemble du film, je peux pas
dire que j'ai aimé complètement.
Nolin, qui est devenue chanteuse
à cause de Céline et qu
l'a rencontrée à deux reprises.
SAFIA NOLIN, auteure-
compositrice-interprète
une chanteuse qui est amoureuses
vieux puis qui veut des bébés,
puis que ça marche pas. C'du fis
je trouve sa poche, parce quemo.
elle a tellement de layers.
- La chanteuse Pifférent ici.
POMME, auteure-compositrice-
interprète
- Je pense que le film va être
reçu complète,
en France, on a beaucoup moins
de détails sur s
- Mais Valérie Lemercier est
catégorique : ce film est
une lelé au grain
tout le temps pour qu'on sente
l'amour qui transpire de cette
famille-là, de ce couple-là,
de cette fratrieque ça quique ç.
Et les pièges, je les ai pas...
je les ai pas vus.
- Elle n'a pas rencontré la
diva, " et que le film lui
plaira.
- J'ai fait dire depuis deux ans
que si elle veut voir le film,
veut. Et son fils a demandé
à voir le film hier et
on le lui a envoyé.
♪ I feel that I'm alive ♪
- "Aline" prendra l'affiche
au Québec le 25 novembre.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Charti
Radio-Canada, M